good morning Millennials for the very
last time welcome back to the morning
toast happy Monday hope your Rising
grinding hustle and bustling doing Mogul
Tings because I know we are okay that's
misleading for the very last time it
sounds like sorry for the very last time
I'm not dying no today our secret
project labors will bear fruit and we
can announce what we've been working on
and the lead time is so short I don't
feel like we were even that annoying
about being secretive but do you know
how much worse we could have been we
could have been so much worse and the
secret project is multi-faceted the
biggest actually depends people might
say different things are the biggest
thing because they're all so big but one
really big thing is that we have
rebranded the show from the morning
toast to be the toast
so let's talk a little bit how we came
to that conclusion we you've been
talking for a while about how you hated
our former artwork even though I made it
and it was really hurtful you weren't
wrong
um it was you know we were outgrowing it
so we met with a creative agency and
like we were doing this whole Rebrand
and we had this long call they wanted to
get to know us get to know the show and
we didn't even realize like as we were
telling them all about the toast
he was like you know you guys haven't
called it the morning toast once like
you've literally only said the toast and
me and Jackie looked at each other and
we were like oh my God yeah and with our
new setup we've you know obviously not
been able to post the episode so early
because we're trying to do high quality
video which takes a long time to get
uploaded so we've been releasing at like
12 30 1 o'clock in the last couple of
weeks and that's how we're going to be
doing it moving forward so when he said
that me and Jackie just looked at each
other and we were like oh duh Presto
also it's crazy we're going on five
years of doing the show and the show now
is so different from what we started as
and what we thought the show would be
when we first started and what we wanted
it to be versus like where we are now
which is like we are podcasters we love
podcasting in the show Even though
people love it on YouTube it will always
be on YouTube and we love doing video
it's really a podcast and I think when
we started we were like this like parody
Morning Show so we were like the morning
toast but we've grown up and everyone
calls it the toast and it is just the
toast like the morning the morning was
holding us back
oh a hundred percent like the pressure
we felt like get it up as early as
possible like at at what cost you know
yeah and this doesn't mean that now
we're gonna like be putting it out later
and later and later but it's just a
podcast I don't know what other podcasts
that have like mourning in the title and
every time we release it at different
times every day depending on the length
of the episode and it's just
it was time
so just know like absolutely nothing
changes the show is exactly the same
Jackson clotter exactly the same we're
still going to be putting it up as soon
as we can which is usually around 12 or
1 o'clock
um the content Remains the Same yeah and
that's video is by one o'clock like the
podcast is always a lickety-split
lickety split so that is the first kind
of huge we have new artwork if you're
listening on your podcast app your
podcast app should have um updated to
our new artwork our new name our new
artwork is so sickening I haven't been
able to stop staring at it since we got
it it's the background of my phone
because I look so stunning it's so
sickening and we have a new logo it's
just a facelift it's not so different
The Branding isn't all of a sudden gonna
be you know like
futuristic or no no it's still girly and
fun and classic but just a little
facelift a little tweak yeah like the
brand needs to mature as we mature you
know and we're getting old you like
we've really matured and now the brand
is coming with us and I feel like it's
just the logical Next Step
100 and it just happened at a great time
because the second part of our
announcement which is equally as big I
think yeah is we have officially joined
the dear media family so we've been
working on this deal like the entire
summer I'm so excited to finally
announce it Jackie and I's former
podcast contract came up and we were you
know we were talking to the bigwigs like
let's be real like we were in it
um and when the deer media idea came
across the table I think Jackie and I
like immediately gravitated towards it
like I was really excited about it
because I love Lauren and Michael I
think they're so smart and it's just
like always important to work with
people who you respect 100
and we decided to move forward with them
and it was like a really long process
and they I think part of the reason I
was particularly so excited is because
it turns out everyone who works at Gear
Media and their headquarters in La is a
toaster so it's so important that the
people that you work with like get what
you do yeah to be surrounded by toasters
it's like-minded individuals yeah so we
are starting today officially part of
the deer media family so is TNN all of
our TNN shows are now a part of deer
media nothing changes that doesn't
really mean anything for you it's just
you know a little back-end Mogul Ting
for us it's kind of b2c but I mean b to
B but I do feel like deer media is more
of a consumer-facing brand than some of
the other networks and bigwigs we were
talking to so it is really exciting for
everyone yeah no it's I'm I'm like
thrilled with our decision and it feels
good to like have the fruits of our
labor in terms of our secret project
finally be revealed yes um
so that's the second part of the
announcement the third part oh is like
and I'm sure a lot of you guys have
noticed this but as a part of our deal
um dear Media made a Strategic
investment in spirit society which is
our canned Cocktails so a lot of you
guys have been sending me um they've
been like putting you know a little
product placement in a lot of their
videos a lot of their podcasters have
been drinking it while having guests in
studio so people are like oh my god look
like they're drinking spreads like yeah
we know yeah it's just one big family
now between the toast tmn spread steer
media Lord and Michael sounds like we're
saying Lauren Michaels but we're talking
literally Lauren and Michael Bostic the
skinny confidential family too family
Tings I'm so excited about this next
chapter for us I'm excited too it's a
new era I feel like we've naturally just
been in a new era so to have everything
else that we're doing reflect this new
season feels really good and apt if
you're watching on YouTube you probably
notice we have removed our old mic flags
with our former logo the new ones should
be arriving soon they take so long to
get made so don't be alarmed you know a
rebound is really a big undertaking I
mean we talk about other rebrands all
the time they have to change everything
I think you know compared to Subway like
our Rebrand is a little smaller and more
manageable rebrands should be small like
a successful Rebrand no no no no not
changing the logo like in a crazy way I
mean like they have to change like
everything at every single store
we have some like mic flags and you know
some artwork on our Instagram yeah but
it's Rebrand is a Rebrand and you know
that we love them no matter when and how
they come
speaking of Instagram we have a new
Instagram handle it is at the toast and
if you want to see pictures from our
sickening photo shoot we did two really
cute looks for our
um podcast cover art we weren't sure
which way we're gonna go we obviously
had to do you know succession Vibes
females in charge power suits and that's
what we ended up going with but we also
did like a very retro shoot
um it was giving Mad Men it was giving
why women kill we were like 50s
Housewives because when we were
explaining like kind of our brand
aesthetic to our creative
um agency we were like we are these
modern women like we are female business
owners Moguls but we're also like you
know traditional Queens like we keep
Shabbos we're married like we're also
like very old school in a lot of ways
yeah so it was a marriage of those two
ideas and we ended up going with the
power suit look for the artwork but we
really wanted to show you guys our uh
looks for the 50s housewife because
honestly I've never been more obsessed
with anything in my life and you guys
know like my hair is my protector you
know it's
Christian Cole you know it protects me
no don't even don't even know I know no
I know I know sorry what was the other
guy's name who burned at um it takes me
10 seconds to figure it out because I
have to
sir Lord strong Harwin
Harwin Harwin it's my Lord Harwin so I
was thinking about it as I was going to
sleep and I can never remember his name
at first but if I start from strong I
can get there got it well so I had to
put my hair up I had bangs and I was
really kind of like nervous about it I
was like there's no way we're ever gonna
use these pictures they will never see
the light of day but I think I was born
in the wrong era because like take a
look at me in those photos and you're
gonna be like oh yeah no and what's so
funny is we did the suits Vibe first and
it's obviously you know now women
wearing suits is like duh but yeah it's
technically like back in the day it was
like a crazy thing to do so we're like
wearing quote unquote men's suits and
then we put on these dresses these
housewife dresses and we did our hair
like 50s and we went all the way and I
think at first like we thought we looked
a little silly but then we started
looking at the pictures and we looked
amazing
we were like uh now we get white women
wear these dresses because we look like
the [ __ ] snatchers oh my God like an
a-line empire waist short sleeve polka
dot address is my look who would have
thunk they were really on to something
which was also so funny is like so I
wear my hair in like little uh pinned
rolling curls and when I took it down I
had the most gorgeous wave and I was
like they were really on to something uh
I couldn't get my hair to hold a wave
all day because it was before I got my
hair cut all of a sudden I'm doing 50s
hair wave
wave wave
so that's the big mobile news
um you're welcome for not making you way
too long and being annoying and teasing
it because we've known about this like
since literally May so uh I'm very
excited we hope you guys are excited and
woohoo
woohoo so
now we'll be back to business as usual
but just today feels like a very
exciting day we don't really have that
many
crazy news stories no no no not about
the news I'm just saying like in this
industry in this job like every day is
kind of same like today I woke up and I
was like it's Carnation Day no it's when
I tell you today Jackie when I tell you
I did not sleep and my dreams my dreams
were about like launching on Instagram
because we have all these like cool
pictures going up and I like [ __ ] it
up in my dream and I woke up and I went
back to sleep I'm like oh thank God I
didn't oversleep because we woke up a
little extra early today and I went back
to sleep and I had the same dream
wow it's a lesson no like I'm you're
right like it's coronation day yeah the
winter is open so is that door I didn't
know they did that they did that oh we
can't sing together anymore that's how I
know no that's kind of like nature
healing because I think we were really
losing listeners like that's so crazy to
me like I know I just can't wrap my head
around it those listeners don't support
women in the Arts those listeners it's
just like I guess it's not their Vibe
like if you can't relate to bursting out
into song On Any Given possible chance
like and that doesn't spark joy for you
I can't relate I really can't and
there's no no shade towards you like
neither one of us is right or wrong it's
just like no no my kind of people burst
out into song
my kind of folk by beer on Friday get
right on Saturday night
um before I forget also today's like
such a busy day tonight I'm gonna be in
Long Island at Westbury Plaza the total
wine at Westbury Plaza at 5 45. for
spritz meet and greet we can all drink
and celebrate the new era of the toast
so I hope to see you guys there on Long
Island the total wine we're doing a
spritz meet and greet Total Wine
Westbury Plaza 5 45 p.m eastern time
tonight I can't wait to see you guys
there awesome and tonight I will be
recording the redheads I just finished
the redheads book and it was so amazing
oh it was so incredible like I wish I
had to read it within like two to three
days because I started it Friday night I
had to be done today
and I finished it last night and like I
wish I could have drawn it out longer
and not Joy I was like reading during
every single break that I had I was like
reading on the plane when like Harry was
quiet for two seconds I was like picking
up my book
um and it was so delightful and I think
all the girls loved it I would recommend
it to anyone we've read lessons in
chemistry by Bonnie garments it already
had amazing reviews and I can concur
that it was really incredible and if you
have questions about the book or
anything else about reading email us at
heads book club gmail.com I will sift
through all the spam to get to your
questions
oh and then the episode goes up on
Thursday and redheads is moving to Dear
media I know people were really really
nervous about like what does this means
about the redheads getting left behind
they're like what does this mean for the
redhead it's like cool for the toast but
what does it mean for the redheads and
it means the redheads go unchanged
that's what I mean wait I totally forgot
to tell you on that note I joined a book
club excuse
you're not like a podcast book club like
a social book club you know like with
him with like people in real life they
too
um my friend Abe who by the way um I
recorded a podcast with on the patreon
people are always asking me like who is
Abe So we did like a whole thing
um my friend Abe Margo fish and my
friend Raquel
okay and so it's once a month
well like we're already having a hard
time scheduling the first Italian
because like Raquel's going to Israel
I'm gonna be in Florida in November it's
like it's gonna be
um it's gonna be tough but we chose the
book what's the book
the last thing he told me I
okay not good
not working I'll tell the group now I'll
tell your time you personally won't like
it and it's just like a much rapidly
three stars hold on wait let me write in
the book club honestly you guys should
read lessons in chemistry because it's a
great book club book it's worth your
time
wait Jackie says we will not lick the
book no like maybe someone won't hate it
but Dana read it I read and we're just
like meh
oh my God I'm so glad I asked you
because like it was a lot of pressure
like nobody wanted to be the first one
to choose so I I didn't but then Raquel
suggested it and like I've seen it all
over Goodreads the time I want to read
like so I'm like oh okay yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] oh man you just saved us like so
like imagine if we started off the book
club on such a bad note we'd never get
to meeting number two yeah but I mean
sometimes a bad book can Bond people but
the problem with that book is that it's
not even bad it's not it's neither good
it's just book
book yeah it doesn't Inspire
conversation crisis averted try lessons
in chemistry it's so good and if you are
not a redhead it is literally never too
late you could go to Amazon go to Libby
go to your local library and get the
book today and join us all of our
episodes are evergreen you can listen to
them literally from three years ago you
can listen now and it'll feel like we
just recorded it oh and a testament to
that is the reason why we're starting
this book club because I've been
hounding Abe to start reading he bought
a Kindle like two years ago at my
request and he's like I don't understand
but he finally got into it and now he
wants to start a book club and he read a
lot of uh like a couple of books that
had been redheads episode so he goes
back and listens like he loved the red
white and royal blue episode he was like
I'm cracking up that is so funny I
literally don't even remember recording
it but I'm glad it still holds well he
was like I loved the book so much and
then I listened to the episode and like
I kind of like realized things like
maybe it wasn't that good you know when
you're forced to talk about a book for
an hour you inevitably like nitpick have
to critique it and do you like that's
what even we do with books that we love
it doesn't change how much I love the
book but definitely other people will be
like didn't you think that was weird and
I'm like oh I didn't notice it yeah I
guess that's weird or like a plot hole
that you just noticed loose ends that
didn't tie up I feel like that'll happen
a little bit with this book that we just
read but
they can't turn me away from how much I
loved it
I am reading city of likes I'm being
like so slow with this book I've had no
time
um and I think I'm only like 25 through
it's by Jenny Mullen and it's all about
like Instagram and like you know New
York sensors
and I really feel like she took a lot of
inspiration from real life like not that
the people are anything like each other
but I felt like the main character
Daphne who's like this fabulous gorgeous
Rich mom influencer was heavily inspired
by Ariel charnis like I just I am like a
lot of the way she was describing like
her family and her kids I'm like oh my
God this is Ariel turnes and then
obviously Chelsea house is so wow yeah I
didn't think of Ariel charnis once maybe
just because of the way her style was it
didn't make me or because she was blonde
because she was blonde and she was very
like
pop and like Ariel turn this is like
very like minimal and classic I just
meant like her career and Her Image like
how she's literally so famous her kids
are so famous and everyone is obsessed
with her kids like it just really
reminded me of Ariel Turner it reminds
me more of like Kiara frog me
oh okay that's good that you should play
her in the movie if they make a movie
there was one other thing that was like
so real life I can't remember I was like
oh I know exactly where she pulled
inspiration from I can't remember but I
feel like schools I have kids schools no
no because like I don't know anything
about like the New York City like school
nursery games right and the way people
talk about it like it is The Hunger
Games I but it is actually like that
yeah
yeah so that's what I'm reading I'm
being slow
um but I watched so much TV obviously
we're gonna do the house of the Dragon
recap and then I want to talk a little
bit about do Revenge okay which is that
Netflix movie with Cami Mendez that I
watched and I watched the Family Stone
for the first time have you ever watched
it
it's like a classic holiday movie like
it's literally like the holiday
um people are obsessed that it has like
a cult following and for some reason I
realized I'd never seen it and I was
like in the mood because I was making a
chili yesterday I was in the mood to
watch like holiday movies and I have a
lot of thoughts so I'll talk about all
that in the TV recap okay great
um I was in the middle of ordering
groceries and I forgot and I have no
food so I literally need to do that
while you read the ads thank you for
reminding me with your chili
um so without further Ado and this part
is gonna be workshopped as we settle
into our Rebrand
mcclurtia your cards are off brand oh oh
my God I forgot the thing about rebrands
there's so much that's what I said
that's what I meant about like subway
like the cups yeah we need new cards
okay mcclaria your curds are off brand
the strikes brothers are doing well
Bruno's working on his Memoirs that's
why he's not in studio with me right now
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before
you
um
sound off in the comments if you have
any good suggestions I think we might
need to depart entirely like it's time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know and then everything else should
change like that you need to know
before you finishing before no I think
think stop thinking like of toast in the
morning like maybe start thinking like
no we need to use the crunch sound
cheers toast and we have a clink sound
next oh that's cute okay let's Workshop
it and let's just play the crunch now
for old time's sake
Fab
um today's episode of the toast is
brought to you by bowling Branch because
some things never change even in a
Rebrand bowling Branch focuses on thread
quality so their sheets feel impossibly
soft and luxurious because it doesn't
matter how many threads your sheets have
if they're not made with the best
organic cotton fibers in the world we
are bowling Branch girlies beds are
extremely important to us and we just
can't lay in any bed you know we like
the best of the best and that's why
we're bowling Branch curlies Jackie and
I both have both have the Signature
Collection from Bowling Branch we both
have it in white and we both have
king-sized beds but they have a bunch of
different sizes a bunch of different
colors whatever the aesthetic of your
bedroom is bowling branch is here to
help you elevate that aesthetic
super comfortable super breathable if
you're a warm sleeper and you wake up
with night sweats like I do you need a
fabric that is breathable that's also
going to keep you warm and cool during
the cold Seasons it is everything of the
sort
um it's actually so fabulous it's not
only beloved by two Peabody
award-winning podcast hosts but also by
three U.S presidents so the signature
hem sheets from Bowling Branch are the
best selling set for a reason they're
made from the highest quality threads
they have a superior softness and
they're going to ensure a better night's
sleep they have over 25 000 Rave
customer reviews they're buttery cozy
super breathable and they're perfect for
every season they come in nine different
colors like I said and they fit all
mattress sizes you will feel the
difference the moment you lie down best
of all bowl and Branch gives you a 30
night risk-free trial with free shipping
and Returns on all orders
you can try the sheets that will make
fall the coziest season of the year
we're entering that time it's October
1st we're all watching Hocus Pocus too
like don't be
he asked me what day it was it's October
3rd sorry it's October 3rd
um
and it's like elevate your space we're
spending a lot more time indoors now
it's chilly and you're making chili so
you need me you need you need sheets
that match that you need gorgeous sheets
that you can stain with your chili a
hundred percent and they wash really
well they get better with every wash get
15 off your first set of sheets and free
shipping when you use promo code toast
at bowlingbranch.com that's bowling
Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by thuma
let me be yours
it can be really frustrating and
disappointing when you get a bed and it
shows up in 4 000 boxes and you have to
contemplate divorce before the bed
actually gets assembled it ain't right
but that's why if you're refreshing your
bedroom now is the perfect time to
elevate the most important bed in your
home with thuma the bed by thuma is
handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood you'll find
beautiful unique variations in the
natural grain the minimalist design
which features Japanese joinery helps
Elevate any space very supportive for
your mattress it's breathable and it's
made to naturally minimize noise and
create space so the perfect platform bed
just got better you can now customize
the bed by thuma by choosing between the
original pillow board their new solid
wood headboard and the fabric pillow
board adds softness and color
to any space while the headboard offers
solid Sleek support it attaches directly
to the bed that headboard using Japanese
joinery which means no tools required
you can buy it with the bed or on its
own as an upgrade so if you've ever set
up Furniture you know it's literally
hell on Earth and it is demonic and it
should not be real
um and that's why the bed by thumb is so
fabulous it comes in three easy to
maneuver boxes it can be set up in less
than five minutes and you and your
partner will not need to break up in
order to get a good night's sleep and I
feel like that is a value like you
really can't put a price on no no they
also other offer other bedtime
Essentials like the mattress the
nightstand the side table and they're
all perfectly complementary to the bed
so you can have a really fabulous vibe
in your home create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma now go to thuma.co toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bed plus free shipping
and in the continental US by the way
free shipping on a bed is is pretty
sickening go to thuma.co toast that's
t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash toast for 25
credit through them the bed for
laypeople
100
okay are you ready for our stories
I am there's a cross between the cough
and a laugh first up Prince George says
are you serious I'm kidding
I'm like this [ __ ] [ __ ] on the day
of our Rebrand I'm kidding oh my God I
was like there's no there's literally no
[ __ ] I've been working on that joke
since Friday oh by the way that's a good
one thank you thanks Claudia
that was a cough
yeah I could tell
um okay first story some exciting couple
news that we ship no matter where they
stand
exes Lily James and Matt Smith were
spotted at the same London party more
than two years after they split Lily
James and Matt Smith may have had an
unexpected run-in on September 30th over
two years after they broke up the
ex-lovers were both spotted partying at
the Children's Firehouse a luxury
restaurant and hotel located in the West
End of London Lily and Matt apparently
each stayed out until around five in the
morning when they went home separately
within just a few minutes of each other
it's unclear if what happened inside the
party but that's the information that we
have and I think that it's there's
something there
let me tell you why this is so exciting
are you ready to hear white I think I
know why can I guess because I could I
guess yeah that because when they were
dating you didn't know them from Adam
and you couldn't appreciate it and now
you love them both so dearly and they're
coming back together so that you can
appreciate it
oh my God yes exactly like I felt like I
totally missed the boat because I wasn't
a Matt Smith stand I hadn't seen Downton
Abbey yet so I didn't really know
anything about Lily James like I wasn't
invested in either of them enough to
like give a [ __ ] about the relationship
and now there's many different channels
I become obsessed with Lily James
Downton Abbey Pam and Tommy like she is
that girl and of course I'm head over
heels in love with live my life out on
the line took several bullets for Damon
Targaryen AKA Matt Smith
um and I knew him before you know he was
in the crown I didn't care so now that
like my P my interest has peaked with
both of them and then I was too late I
found out that they dated five years ago
that was upsetting now that there's even
a glimmer of hope even if it's the just
a pure coincidence they were at the same
event the fact that I can be a part of
it like as somebody who's like so
desperate to be a part of things this is
overwhelming it really is I agree
they're giving us an opportunity to be a
part of it I don't know if this thing
has legs but I do think it means
something that they were at the same
party and they left at the same time and
that time was 5 a.m like
it's not like they just left it then
that ended and they had to leave at the
same time I think this means a little
something it might just be like X's
finding comfort in one another
so be nothing innocuous happens at 5am
like something's going on something in
the fairies
no not nefarious something wonderful
something wonderful
that did remind me something I wanted to
talk about in The Game of Thrones finale
is like why I'm problematic that was the
finale
sorry no I don't know why I said that
okay even though it kind of had finale
Vibes no no no no no I saw preview for
next week sorry it was just like a slip
I I don't I know nothing like is that
not clear like when you tune into the
show you're not gonna get facts like
you're just gonna get like music okay no
but that's something that you wouldn't
know but I did see the preview next for
next week so she misspoke yeah no sorry
I meant episode um and just remind me
like when we talk
at the end like remind me to explain to
you why I'm a problematic girl okay okay
I will
um thank you and now for our next story
which was requested by Claudia
um yes which is an interesting story Lil
Mouse X delays his concert to poop
backstage he said quote I'm quote
dropping demons Lil Nas X candidly told
Atlanta concert goers in the middle of a
show Thursday that he needed a bathroom
break quote I'm backstage and this is
like not a part of the show but I'm
taking a mean [ __ ] so please forgive me
the rapper said noting that he only
needed a minute or two on the toilet
I'll be right back the Grammy winner
promised in a viral video filmed by an
audience member on Friday the songwriter
took to Twitter to clarify that he
wasn't kidding about delaying the show
to drop a deuce quote LMAO people really
thought I was joking I was literally
back there dropping demons into that
toilet
so it wasn't in the middle of the show
it was before
um well he said it on he like told them
I think that
he went off stage and pooped and came
back
okay I mean this is just like the reason
middle of the show The Middle of the
show I said Okay the reason why I wanted
to talk about it is like thank you like
this is so relatable I always think and
like I'm a performer my shows are only
an hour maybe an hour and a half
um
so like I keep my ass cheeks tight
but I do often think like people who
give three hour concerts and a lot of
them like drink on stage like I just
wonder like how do none of them take
dumbs and maybe there are things they do
day of the show like you know Imodium
something that you know
blocks their bowels but I often think
like how has there really never been
anyone who had to like leave stage to go
poop I'm sure there have been but like
you always also like athletes athletes
yeah I mean what about us we do the show
an hour and a half and we sit here
and I feel like we're always talking
about how we have to pay we always have
to pee but we really I think only when I
was pregnant did I ever get up to go pee
in the middle but you could pee in the
middle of a concert as a performer you
have wardrobe changes and they always
send out a guy with his guitar solo
I think so too and they introduce the
band members I'm not gonna lie like yes
this is relatable but it's TMI like but
I think that no I think it's funny
the descriptors of these like uh
fire Deuces that he's dropping like I'm
good personally I think that it's
a little too far for me but I'm glad
that you found joy in it
no I didn't find Joy I'm glad you found
joy in the Twin Lil Mouse's toilet bowl
I appreciated the candidness the
straightforward the transparency the
honesty and then it's just always like
that and then it just like made me think
how this doesn't happen more often I'm
sure it does happen but also the body
has a way
yes of doing what it needs to do and
unless you like were sick that day with
food poisoning like you probably won't
be able to hold it not hold it in you
know even if like you yeah your body on
stage like you could wait until you got
off stage
no because I often think about how like
I've literally I've done like 150 comedy
shows I've never sneezed
now you're gonna be sneezing up a storm
well I would love to sneeze because like
I have a kind of like an amazing
beautiful sneeze yeah and people should
see it live in person but you're right
like your body has a way maybe it's
adrenaline of like acting right even if
you're even if you are sick like one
time I I had like trouble I was in
Houston and like before the show like I
I had diarrhea
um and I went on stage and like [ __ ]
just gets right
like it acts right yeah
um but then it made me think have you
seen the video like going viral of the
like the pop-up toilet on the football
field no
they have like a pop-up toilet it's like
it's like this tent that like lifts up
you know like you know those um
okay whatever it's like a tent okay by
convention and you're like totally
private but like you are taking a dump
in front of a hundred thousand people
okay I don't think athletes on the
regular need to take a dump in the
middle of the game
is a few feet away so unless you're Tom
Brady but even he gets a break when
they're on defense yeah
people need to be yeah and you know what
I feel like you're bowels I mean some
people have
and we also read like unbirding
yourselves where it's like actually
people can't hold it in right hold it I
feel like I unless I'm sick
I can hold it
well a lot of people have IBS right
that's what I'm saying that's what I've
learned through on birding yourselves
it's been very educational that like
there are a lot of stomach issues out
there
um also a little fun fact is like most
theaters and I imagine that
even the ones I haven't been to and like
football fields and basketball courts
most theaters have a toilet right on
side stage that's not a part of your
dressing room like your dressing room is
maybe downstairs or upstairs but like
nine times out of ten there's like a
door by the stage entrance with a toilet
and they always show you like just in
case an emergency like there's literally
a toilet right here so it's thought of
yeah I usually like you said it was a
one to two minute poop he could he
didn't need to say anything but I think
it's you know funny and people obviously
got to charge it and he is like always
trolling people that's why I think a lot
of people thought it wasn't real yeah I
just and I know we talk about poop a lot
on this show inadvertently
um so I'm not really one to talk it's
just like a lot of poop you know
yeah no I find I I agree that sometimes
you know like a poop joke it's like poop
joke is like the lowest form of humor
but sometimes it's actually just funny
um are you ready for our next story a
little financial news
Kim Kardashian agrees to pay 1.26
million dollars to settle SEC crypto
charges Kim Kardashian has agreed to
settle charges from the U.S Security and
Exchange Commission the SEC for touting
on social media a crypto asset security
offered and sold by ethereum Max without
disclosing the payments you received for
the promotion the SEC announced the
charges on Monday in an official release
and stated that Kim quote agreed to
settle the charges pay 1.26 million
dollars in penalties disgorgement and
interest and cooperate with the
commission's ongoing investigation
without admitting or denying the sec's
findings according to the group Kim
violated protocols when she didn't
reveal that she received a quarter of a
million dollars to make an Instagram
post promoting ethereum Max's emacs
tokens a crypto asset security product
along with a link to the company's
website for would-be purchasers the SEC
said um no I'm sorry Kim's lawyer said
Kim Miss Kardashian is pleased to have
resolved this matter with the SEC she
fully cooperated with the SEC from the
very beginning and she remains willing
to do whatever she can to assist the SEC
in this matter this is kind of crazy and
this is what they're always warning you
about like if you don't put ad on your
post like the FTC or the FCC can come
for you I think that because this is
crypto
yeah no this is not like if I remember a
little while ago I think JLo got in
trouble for like an FTC violation for
not disclosing hashtag ad that is like a
especially when you're a content creator
who does brand deals like you always
hear like you could get suede but this
is like not what Kim did was like dead
ass illegal like that's like remember
when Elon Musk was like I'm gonna take
uh Tesla private so then the price of
his stock went up so much because
everybody went to buy it that's like
moving the market with your platform and
that's like fully illegal like and I
actually remember when Kim did these
stories and a bunch of people did them I
was like this is such a weird sponsored
post because it's like it's like
influencing the market that's okay fine
I agree
let's talk about the post in a second
but the idea that like someone could say
something that influences trends like
there are so many business shows like
that like what about Jim Cramer like how
is that different no
buys it the price goes up
because Jim has no um actually it's just
a level of success you know people
listen to it I don't think that's it
like I'm not sure what the difference is
but there's a difference you that's a
really good point and I don't have a
rebuttal but I know that there is one do
you know what I mean I'm sure there is
one but it's very slight and I think
it's a gray line
and I don't know if Jim Cramer gets on
and tells you exactly what to buy isn't
that his job
no it's to like report on what happened
everyone saw the funniest meme that like
was um a list of all the stocks that Jim
Cramer has told people to buy over the
like literally every single one and they
are all in the red so you should
actually do the opposite of what Jim
Cramer says is that just because we're
like headed for a recession
like that we that's an aside they are
bad stock tips
no shade to Jim Cramer that's a team of
shade
no that's interesting yeah but like [ __ ]
like this is very touchy like you cannot
even when we used to do remember how
Robin Hood was one of our big sponsors I
remember in the copy they used to send
over there was this huge disclaimer you
cannot suggest
stocks stocks are companies for people
to buy like it's a huge violation so Kim
Kim's thing is totally illegal the Jim
Cramer thing is like an amazing point
that I need further because like you're
right but like you have to be wrong you
know what I mean right sound off in the
comments
yeah like why is what Jim Cramer does
not illegal and like any other any other
family joke he's just you know the one I
know
yeah I mean Kim's was like so obvious
also I feel like Kim must be having a a
moment of reflection between this and
the giveaways it's like why are she why
is she doing I mean she got paid a
quarter of a million dollars for this
but honestly wasn't enough considering
it cost her a million point two five and
now she's in another lawsuit and I just
feel like she has so many businesses
legit companies want to work with her
like at a certain point you should say
no maybe I think that's a lesson she
might be learning today that's so true I
forgot also about the lawsuit like these
boys these sponsored posts are becoming
more trouble than they're worth
no you're so right everybody likes to
make an example out of Kim you know how
many giveaways do people do how many uh
other people promote weird [ __ ] on
Instagram but it's Kim who's gonna be
made the example of because she is the
biggest one doing it and recently so
much of what Kim does is so legitimate
her starting that BC firm with the guy
from Blackstone like Carlisle so
Carlisle so high brow you know like she
keeps reaching new levels of legitimacy
and then there's like elements that are
so tacky like the giveaways like it's
just a you don't have a VC with Carlisle
group and a Louis Vuitton giveaway yeah
I also feel like I remember back in the
day she promoted some Pharma thing and
it was an issue do you remember does
this ringing a bell I can't I know that
she's done sponsored posts with like
botox the company and then like four
stories afterwards it's like all these
long like credit a credit of disclaimers
yeah no but I don't remember her getting
like um
sued for that though
hold on because there are a bunch of
people who work with botox like Simon
Huck is like does
um a lot of really good sponsor content
for Botox and then there's always like a
huge caption of disclaimers and yeah no
this was FDA and manish's Drug maker
over Kim Kardashian Instagram post the
post was now removed but it went uh it
was talking about morning sickness the
thing was dislike de clagus
um well Chloe also is the face of nerd
Tech otd yeah the FDA had said that the
URLs were insufficient and inconsistent
with the full material information
required when such a drug is advertised
in any medium
and with like with this is there any um
bearing on the company or just Kim
because they're also like isn't there a
responsibility on the company to make
sure that like the content they're
paying to be put out has full
disclosures
true like is urethiam whatever it was
called the crypto company are they being
sued as well yeah and also this harks
back to fire Festival where it's like
the people who promoted it weren't sued
the people who created it were
right like where in situations like this
like where does the liability lay no and
what's the difference between that and
this
yeah no that's a good point
um
just so many so many Financial questions
this morning is what she's being sued
for it said because she didn't disclose
how much she got paid she didn't
disclose let me get back because it said
like the amount that she was paid was I
think without disclosing that she was
paid is mine no read it again for
touting on social media crypto asset
security offered and sold by ethereum
Max without disclosing the payment she
received for the promotion that's could
be either or oh it could be because it
sounds like well if she wrote hashtag ad
but not hashtag I was paid 250k or or
just that there was no disclosure at all
which is a rookie mistake for Kim
especially in a new space like crypto
yeah
without disclosing the payment
the payment that makes it seem like she
didn't put hashtag ad which I come on
yes this is what she said on her
Instagram story up back when she posted
it are you guys into crypto this is not
Financial advice but sharing what my
friends just told me about the ethereum
max token a few minutes ago ethereum Max
burned 400 trillion tokens literally 50
of their admin wallet giving back to the
entire emacs community
they said she violated the anti-touting
provision of the federal Securities Law
that's like intentionally
trying to make people think you weren't
paid yeah and she oh that is illegal she
also agreed not to promote any crypto
asset Securities for three years
oh girl he's in trouble she's in trouble
with this well you know I love Kim like
she's wrong for this one like she's like
there's full proof but she's cooperating
as her lawyer said she's paying the
piper 100 also speaking of Kim her
podcast dropped today with Spotify
uh which is exciting because we heard
about it a while ago so now it's here
huge podcast news for the industry today
I know it's a day of podcast news and
like the whole family is out killing it
in Paris killing it Chloe Chloe Kylie
took over Paris fashion week it's it's
Kylie Fashion Week now for sure but
you'd love to see Chloe like finally
getting the respect that she deserves
yes totally
I love that for her totally okay our
next story is a little hurricane Ian
news because I want to just take a
moment to terrible share our thoughts
and anyone who's in oh how was your
house when you got back I know you
weren't in like the eye of it we weren't
in the eye of it everything here looked
fine I haven't noticed anything
um okay thank God but people up further
north in Florida right into Naples and
Fort Myers are just really struggling
the Orlando area and a little celeb news
hurricane Ian causes 10 million dollars
of damage to the Queen of Versailles
Stars Mansion oh my God that Mansion is
hurt it's literally cursed okay if you
guys have never seen the documentary
Queen of Versailles you absolutely have
to it's one of the best documentaries
ever it catches a little teaser here's a
little teaser they're doing a
documentary on the biggest residential
home being created in America they
follow this family in Florida they're
making the biggest square footage based
on Versailles
the biggest residential home private
residential home and as they're filming
the documentary the family goes broke
yeah because the recession hits It's
2008. it's a crazy documentary and now
the queen herself Jackie she's like a
podcaster yeah I see her so Queen of
Versailles star Jackie Siegel says the
hurricane and destroyed parts of her
Florida mansion amounting to 10 million
dollars in Damages the socialite
provided TMZ with photos of the
destruction which includes caved in
ceilings should she still own the house
own the house is still being worked on
they were supposed to be done by May
2023 now but now it's pushed back
because of this she explained that the
damages are so steep because she
recently added 24 karat gold molding to
her living room which is now partially
falling to the floor as a result of the
hurricane construction on the 90 000
square foot estate has been put on hold
Siegel said several floors in the home
are flooded and her back patio looks
like a lake she believes pumping out the
water will cost about a hundred thousand
dollars the Orlando area property was
supposed to be completed by May 2023
according to the former model but it
seems that date has now been pushed back
I mean it's like it's a nice pop culture
tie-in but like people literally lost
everything like I don't feel bad for
Jackie Siegel and her 24 Karat molding
you know no no of course but it's an
interesting pop culture tie-in also
interesting to know that they're still
working on the house they still own and
they still own it if you watch your
documentary you probably would have
thought eventually they would have to
have sold it but they didn't and they're
still trying to get the Versailles what
did her husband do for a living he did
time shares
right yeah it was so old school yeah
well I'm sending love to all of our
Florida toasters are okay I really am
especially those who live in Fort Myers
like the footage coming out it's so sad
it's so sad it's like but one of the
biggest hurricanes in like centuries in
the country yeah let me tell you that I
ended up on the strangest side of tick
tock okay
it's like the wives of linemen so I
didn't really know anything about it but
I guess like linemen is this job like
you're like a first responder for crises
so you fly out to Florida for something
like this Puerto Rico you know you go to
areas of Destruction and catastrophe and
you spend time there you obviously do
search and rescue you rebuild it's like
a huge part of your job and there are
these women called like I'm sorry I'm
botching like the verbiage called like
bunny
Boppers or something who like hop on the
line men like and like want to [ __ ] like
oh it's like kind of when athletes come
to your town yeah yeah so like the wife
of the line women have like been making
all these tick tocks being like okay
bunny Chasers like just know that the
linemen have families at home they have
wives and kids who love them like back
off and it's like
the other side of the argument is like
the Buddy Chasers are just like rational
thinking human beings are like well if
your man is like gonna be cheating on
his wife and the mother of his children
like that's also mostly on him also
aren't the men busy isn't there a lot of
work to be done I was just learning so
much men and women how the [ __ ] did I
get here maybe because I was like
engaging with a lot of like hurricane
content the algorithm brought me to like
this dark side of that
conversation I was just like Shook at
first I'm like this is not English I'm
like what are bunny Hoppers I'm botching
the verbiage I'm sorry but it's like the
linemen and the bunny Chasers I I can
follow and I'm fascinated
yeah it was it's so crazy that you think
like oh my God anyone who like goes into
a disaster area to help like hero
um it's the Dark Side of heroin there to
help to cheat on their wives right to
you know pillage no
it was really uh and so do these girls
then the mistresses of the linemen do
they fly into disaster areas as well to
offer their services oh that's
interesting like I don't know no I think
they have to go out to meet these guys
because it would just be like does every
neighborhood have a bunny Chaser and
then when the neighborhood gets hit like
perhaps but I think them you know
traveling to the disaster zones makes a
lot more sense yeah I hope while they're
helping out yeah come on
that's crazy do your part for the
community
that's really crazy I know and like the
hurricane just in general is like so
crazy and so sad like people's entire
lives just like washing away yeah
and there's still like so many people
missing rescue efforts are still
underway I've been seeing like a lot of
footage of rescue efforts like for
people who are like literally
like their house became an island yeah
you know I guess it's really a good
thing about Tick Tock I feel like you've
seen I feel like with anything like you
really get inadvertently a lot of news
yes you do if you engage with that type
of content you know yeah but also I feel
like people who are there and are
posting really compelling things they're
going on the for you page and even if
you choose to you know watch videos of
the Renegade you might be inundated with
that as well which is good yes and I
also think like people are like making
themselves known like oh we're on this
street and our whole neighborhood like
we can't get out yeah like it's a good
um like putting out a call yeah so it
has its benefits for sure are you ready
for our fifth and final story which is
actually also a little documentary news
that's wild
and it's for our 90s babies because
Barney docu-series I Love You You Hate
Me uncovers
uncovers the dark side of the kids show
so a trailer just dropped up to Barney
docky series two parts at peacock and
apparently Barney experienced a lot of
negativity death threats and there was
like this hatred for Barney
so I can't relate because like the way
as a child I would have laid down in the
street into oncoming traffic for Barney
but he would never have you do that is
what was so great about Barney I love
you it was such a sweet show so I
thought it was going to be like the
environment was toxic but not safe in
working environment for kids no you're
saying more so like the haters the
rumors like people tearing down Barney
here's how here's the info the core
message of the immensely popular Barney
and Friends kid show was to spread love
and kindness to one another but the
trailer for a new peacock docu-series
highlights the idea that America was not
so eager to accept that message in the
trailer for the upcoming two-part
docu-series I love you you hate me
multiple Talking Heads from Bill Nye the
Science Guy to NBC's Al Roker share
stories of how quickly the world turned
against the friendly dinosaur rejecting
its values of inclusion and respect Bob
West a Barney performer who stepped into
the costume for the happy purple
dinosaur shared that death threats were
made against his entire family quote
they were violent and explicit death and
dismemberment of my family he says in
the trailer they were going to come and
find me and they were gonna kill me much
of the dialogue in the trailer at least
surrounds the show's Creator Cheryl
leech who developed the show in 1992
alongside Kathy Parker and Dennis
deshazer after initially creating home
videos of the Barney character of her
children a splice string of dialogue
from multiple interviews in the trailer
underscores the general purpose of the
Barney character Barney stands for
inclusion acceptance you should love any
everyone we all have Cheryl leech to
thank for that
the peacock docu series was first
announced in November of last year and
hails from the producers of queer eye
the docu-series is set to premiere on
October 12th on peacock and the trailer
has just dropped so I feel like for some
people this trailer like the fact that
there's going to be a documentary about
Barney is just
big news like we were such Barney files
and I'm glad to hear that the you know
it's not like there was like drug use on
set and Barney was like you know
sexually assaulting everyone I think but
I had no idea but it also does make you
wonder like what did happen to Barney
and why why isn't Barney still around
today like Sesame Street do you want to
know why because he was too good for
this world because that's why yeah
that's why we can't have nice things
that is so terrible makes you wonder
what's going on isn't a real person
makes you wonder what's going on with
baby shark like I I hope
cocoa melon
Moana
yeah I mean this is just disgraceful and
a Real Testament to how disgusting the
country we live in is because we can't
even have Barney like that can't even be
a universally accepted content
show yeah
Justice for Barney and I'm interested in
this at all that's not the when you said
there's a Barney documentary that was
certainly not the the content I thought
we were going to be receiving that was
the hatred
you hate me you hate me that's a
hilarious name for the documentary yeah
and if you listen to if you watch the
trailer it's like
but then it like it's like horror but
then it takes like a dark turn yeah like
this
yeah and it's not like
Theodora I wonder how Dora is doing it
makes you think about all your beloved
Kids characters and what they're going
through
I read like a conspiracy theory about
Dora growing up and getting into porn
um
okay like love that for her
um I didn't really believe the
conspiracy theory whatever she chooses
to do
I Empower her to make her own choices
life's about choices Claude
life's about Joy okay I'll stop singing
um there is a new Shania Twain song
though let's start waking up dreaming it
sounds so good I have to listen to it
cool can't wait
um let's dive into TV recap House of the
dragon and then some other crap I
watched this weekend which is brought to
you by ZipRecruiter did you know that
there are over 2.4 million podcasts in
the world currently including the one
you're listening to which is better than
all the others it takes a team of people
to bring these podcasts together and
needless to say hiring the right people
for important roles is crucial whether
you're hiring for your podcast or for
your growing business there's only one
place that makes it easy that's zip
recruiter now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast ZipRecruiter uses
it uses its powerful technology to find
and match the right candidates up with
your job you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply additionally
ZipRecruiter has a complete Suite of
tools that makes it easy to filter
review and rate your candidates four out
of five employers who impose on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day so if you're a fan
of this podcast and you want to try
ZipRecruiter for free you'll need to
spell out this special link it's
ziprecruiter.com toast once again that's
zip zip eight
recruiter.com slash
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire all right let's talk about House
of the Dragon episode last night we
finally
okay here's why I'm probably I watched
the last two episodes back to back so
that I might have to remember what
happened okay cool
so
raniera and Damon [ __ ] they get married
they kiss their blood and it should be
like one of the greatest times of my
life right
but like tell me and and I think like
this is really exposing like why I'm
problematic like tell me why I'm not as
excited about it now that she's grown
like it's disgusting okay I think yes on
the on its head that's problematic I
think you're just attached to the other
actress I think when we fell in love
with Rainier and Damon to begin with it
was the other actress and so you want to
see them together and that's familiarity
this is another person you know and
we're all pretending like it's just 10
years later raniera but
that was the chemistry that you fell in
love with I actually had a really easy
time transitioning to the new actors and
actresses
which was good
I think I had a good time an easy time
transitioning to Allison I think yeah
the actress looks just like her
um and she's really [ __ ] evil and so
is that actress like it it tracks with
raniera just because she's the main
character I'm definitely having a harder
time adjusting yeah it will maybe take a
little time for you but it's really so
crazy how when we left Rainier and Lenor
they thought they had it figured out you
know we're gonna and it was like you
know what good for them yeah modern
relationship we're gonna have our cake
we're gonna eat it too and now 10 years
later like he has to fake his own death
and okay wait
so me and Ben were discussing and I
wasn't entirely sure what happened
because
was it their plan all along to fake
lenor's death or did they really want
that guy to kill Lenor but then him and
Lenor you know came up with the plan to
escape I think it's the second one I
think
um they wanted him to kill Elena I think
that would have been simpler and really
like they can't be together if Lena was
still alive I think they came up with
this plan and I do see you know Lenor
coming back and however many people are
disrupting things I watch Inside the
episode after to see if they said
anything they didn't they just said
Lenor really wanted to be you know
stripped of his like of his
responsibilities and burdens and
nobility and so maybe he will go live in
across an arrow sea and not come back
and I guess to everyone that's the
equivalent of him being dead and Renee
era can remarry
yeah no I just wasn't sure if like this
was a brilliant plan or if I think I
think they left a gap in it on purpose
no I think rhaenyra and Gaiman like
expect him to be dead
got it okay that's like so [ __ ] up um
even though like and because he was like
he was [ __ ] up in his own way but he
was very loyal and honorable and he
wasn't a great husband but like he was a
good friend yeah and he was also ready
to try and be the man she gave him to be
so like that's not the time to kill him
but to let him live the life that he
wants to live it's the time
and then the big scene was all the kids
and it was so upsetting and like
basically last night's episode was
eamon's villain origin story because he
was a nice boy he was a nice boy he was
like the loser and then his cousins were
so [ __ ] mean to him that he's
becoming Joffrey Baratheon and you know
what that's what you get for being mean
to your cousin right and like I think
the eye patch is just gonna be his
trademark villain thing but at least he
has a dragon like it was worth it
allegedly yeah I mean I do think it was
worth it to him the love I have in my
heart for raniero's kids like they're
such [ __ ] cute ass little [ __ ]
like I felt like that scene was so
upsetting and like they wanted to get
down to the bottom of it and nobody
thought to ask Damon's kids what
happened they were literally right there
the girls yeah yeah
he's literally out here punching women
not even women girls
he's disgusting he's disgusting and he
stole their mom's [ __ ] Dragon oh and
he was about to kill one of the raniera
kids yes
yes
no it was totally justified like the
fact that he only lost an eye is a
miracle when it was four against one
yeah no he's really scary now scarier
than ever especially like with Allison
to activate it but I scarier than aegon
like I thought aegon was going to be
probably because it sounds too much of
like a reckless it's just like a
mandress yeah I um I'm having a hard
time with the passing of sir haraway and
maybe because I just watched that
episode but like
when when we cut to 10 years later and
so this is two episodes ago and like
Rainier has her baby they go into the
room where the other kids are and so you
see like she has other kids and then
there's that guy and he's like so
handsome and it's like really this
Modern Family because Leonor is like
passing the baby to
sir Harwin and it was just so gorgeous
and I just no it was all gone all of it
is gone yes now we have we're in our
Raymond era so maybe we'll get some love
from all of them but like and when he
was defending his son even though it's
not his son when they were playing in
the pit like it was just beautiful nope
because like when we met the new
reindeer like her life was [ __ ]
miserable like she was Alison's like
punching bag but then to know she had
this happiness with the man and the kids
like it was nice it was nice and then
Allison and her big dumb moronic friend
had to ruin it scary
scary and he's going to take one of the
kids eyes out now oh my God
hate I hate these people and no I don't
think he'll take one of the kids eyes
out but I think there is a debt that
will be he's gonna enact Revenge he's
gonna enact Revenge and I take back
really all the bad things I said about
the king because you know what like the
way he has not faulted he has not
changed who his Heir is the way he does
not allow anyone to speak ill of his
daughter even though he knows there's
truth to it you know what he's not a bad
guy no he's not and I need him to get
his health intact I need to start going
to the gym eating right because he needs
to chill well now reneer is aligned with
Damon so their claim is stronger they'll
probably have their own kids
and and were they saying that Allison's
son needs to marry Allison's daughter
they will be getting married yeah
okay and viserys thought that Ranier and
Damon getting married was so disgusting
just because of the age
oh and she really needs to stop calling
him uncle
that she must do
like right after they [ __ ] she's like
what is it uncle but also stop you know
what the end of the episode was
what was the end of the episode marriage
yeah London
are going to be siblings they're
probably that was cute because they were
all getting along yeah they're all alone
holding hands at the funeral it was so
cute those girls are good girls good
kids and now they're all that their
grandparents have
yeah and so I think it's there's a lot
of strength on that side but
everyone needs to grow up a little all
that their grandparents have so right
they are The Heirs and heiresses to
Valeria yep Damon yeah yeah also I think
next episode jumps again because there's
new like wearing the patch is a new
actor
are we supposed to keep up but I think
that's it like I think it'll probably be
like five years but the actors are a
little more like adult looking not kids
does rhaenyra change yeah
damn just kids
okay well there's also oh and by the way
when you took off your headphones
because you thought I was gonna give a
spoiler what I said was exactly what it
was I said there was three kids in the
next episode but they all have black of
hair and how could rhaenyra and lane or
have anything but silver hair
so I knew that you know that was going
to be the paternity would be interesting
do you think that rhaenyra and Damon
have kids yeah I do
good yeah I hope okay good the other
things that I watched this weekend were
the first one I watched last night was
the Family Stone which is like this
classic holiday movie that I've
apparently never seen and it was so
[ __ ] good like I first of all you
need to watch it and basically like
Carrie Bradshaw is just the worst in the
movie and like everyone in the family
hates her she's like the new girlfriend
of one of the brothers and she comes in
it's just like horrible and it's just
like fabulous because she's acting so
much like Carrie and Carrie's [ __ ]
words and that is exactly like what
would happen if Carrie went home to like
someone's nice normal family and acted
like Carrie right that's funny so I just
loved it and it was also like sad too
like I cried
then the other thing I really wanted to
talk about was everyone's been talking
about this new Netflix movie do Revenge
they're saying it's like the new Mean
Girls I talked about it and I on the
show too and I told you to watch it
oh I don't even remember I just said
really quickly that I thought it was
great and I loved it and I thought it
was so well done I didn't start with the
positives which was that cami Mendez was
Sensational like she looked amazing she
did amazing it was such a good movie
that um plot twist I was not expecting
like it was just really good it was
beautifully beautiful Lowe's the Miami
backdrop like it was really stunning and
then when me and Ben finished it like we
were talking we were like did you think
it was weird that like the villain was
like unnecessarily wearing like a Jewish
star necklace the whole time and I was
like I couldn't tell if I was like being
a Karen like reaching or if it was like
legitimately problematic so I just
started to research and like see if
anyone was talking about it and I ended
up reading a lot about it
um and the more things that were pointed
out to me by
the like the articles I was reading the
more I realized how [ __ ] up it was
like the first thing is that the movie
is very Loosely based off of this book
strangers on a train which was written
by like a very proud anti-semite
um also the book is referenced in the
movie like um I think
what was her name the freak her friend
Cami mendez's friend Nora
um she was reading it at one point as
like a heart back to like the plot of
the movie being Loosely based off of
this book so that's just like a kind of
weird thing to do and then the more I
thought about like the villain being the
Jew when no one else it wasn't a
religious no they didn't go to a
religious school I didn't know what
religion anybody else was but them to
make it like so obvious that the villain
was Jewish like felt so problematic to
me especially because like he was
villainous because he was like sneaky
manipulative Rich politically
um connected persuasive politically
influential like when he you know
writes off one girl he was like well
there goes your dad's Senate career so
just like him saying that like him his
character being based off of like all of
these anti-semitic tropes while wearing
a Jewish star necklace like I officially
deemed the movie anti-semitic no and I
and I didn't want to I totally agree I
didn't notice he was wearing a Jewish
star necklace while I was watching
otherwise I would have like oh and then
he's using like Jewish terms he's like
at the end he was like oh I'm failing
this is so cute like stop oh stop [ __ ] I
didn't see any of that my TV in my new
house is a little far away from my bed
so I do miss some details
um and I and I didn't want to I didn't
want to give it the official
anti-semitic seal of approval because I
liked it me and Ben loved it no I really
liked it you're 100 right there's
anti-smetic undertones and actually
overtones and it's officially
anti-semitic and we actually even though
we joke a lot we actually don't really
like you say that lightly no it's really
[ __ ] anti-semitic and a lot of what I
read like I wasn't sure whether I wanted
to like decide in my head and you don't
you don't want it to be like you want to
be oh no that's not that bad uh because
the movie's great otherwise because the
movie's great and people point it out to
me in my DMs the actor who plays the
Jewish villain is Jewish the director is
Jewish I don't [ __ ] care it's still
anti-semitic oh and Jews can be
anti-semitic and they could also be like
oblivious to
anti-Semitism and other people and that
they just like
want to be a part of something right so
the thing that I saw that like perfectly
summed it up
um
because people are like why can't a
villain be Jewish and like a villain can
totally be Jewish
um but like when there's one person
representing a minority and then that
one person is the villain like that's
problematic and then I was thinking like
if it was a movie about all white kids
and the one black character was the
villain like that's [ __ ] up yeah and
the villain is being villainous in a way
that's harping around playing on all
those stereotypes and micro and macro
aggressions that right are out there
about Jews or whatever particular
minority right and that the article I
read was like imagine imagine I would be
like that's [ __ ] weird like what the
one character who's black is the villain
like I would think that too yeah
so it really pissed me off and I was so
upset because like when I tell you I
liked the movie but like an hour and
been paused to pee and we realized we
had another hour left I was like you
know what I like I liked it but I was
like we don't have to finish it but I
was like no I love it like Ben loved it
you're crazy that you just watch a movie
that you like and not even finish it
I know it was just too long like movies
over an hour and a half should be TV
shows no I think the opposite there's so
many TV shows that should just be movies
like I sometimes I only have two hours
and like if it's a good movie I want
more of it
yeah so I like a long movie every scene
was you know delightful it was beautiful
until I learned what I learned
and the music was incredible yep
it was very Tick-Tock inspired yeah no
the the Wardrobe was amazing
uh but unfortunately it's gonna be a no
I know I was like really I was me and
Ben were like we could not stop talking
about it we were like what did we just
it's so upsetting it's so upsetting
especially because like
it's not like there was a big swastika
and it was like death to the Jews it was
so subtle and like trying to like almost
subliminally message people that like
Jews are bad like I feel like I would
have been less offended dead ass if
there was a big ass swastika in the
middle because obviously that's
anti-semitic but the fact that like I
had to mull over and be like is it
anti-semitic like and the fact that
because it was so subtle so subtle No
One's Gonna talk about it
um right I'm surprised
I know I was just surprised too Daily
Mail and Newsweek yeah so
that's upsetting you know it's not going
to be talking about it's not gonna
there's not gonna be any controversy
with the movie it's gonna go on to do
great things and this will just be
snowballing and people will just know
and like people will just continue to
watch it continue to get that messaging
and not think twice about it
I know I was like so upset
and I hate to like you know always be
complaining but ABC always be
complaining yeah no I would have
preferred for this movie to not be
anti-semitic
um when I didn't ever see the Jewish
star I thoroughly enjoyed it the thing
is like all they had to do was take the
necklace off all they had to do was take
the necklace off yeah and he could have
just been like a rich annoying white kid
all they had to do was take the necklace
off but they put it on
and they put it on in the final scene
where he was being particularly
villainous and not wearing a shirt so it
was literally the only thing you saw how
did I miss that honestly my bed is
really far away from my TV now Zach said
we need a bigger TV but I thought he was
being dramatic
no maybe maybe I do
um so that's what I watched this weekend
and yeah
yeah oh I watched a little SNL
oh thank you so much for bringing that
up so did I Miles Teller was like his
Peyton Manning in the opening sketch was
so funny
um
I did fall asleep towards the very end
like after we get an updates so I missed
probably like the last one or two
sketches I only watched like four
sketches because I just wanted to get
the tone I wanted to hear his monologue
and then I think the first sketch that
came on was actually really funny so I
kept watching so out of the four that I
watched there was one that was so funny
and that was the be whale bank robbery
Perfection timely relevant what
everyone's talking about and like making
a really funny joke out of it like I
thought that's what SNL should be doing
and yes it was just perfect honestly
I did have one issue with SNL part
mostly I tuned in to see Miles Teller my
boyfriend but I also tuned in to see if
they were going to address the Jake
Novak of it all because like while they
were off break this story blew up on
Tick Tock about the kid I've spoken
about it I won't get into it again and I
wanted to see maybe they would bring him
out on Weekend Update maybe do like a
little sketch a cover of the song like
something or even in that first sketch
when they were like talking about SNL
sketches they had like someone come out
as the corn kid they could have had
someone come out yeah they did the corn
kid so I was like oh my God they're
gonna do it
and they did it which was disappointing
mostly because
I wish they would have but also because
like a thought that I had was like it's
very clear that they take a lot of
inspiration from Tick Tock like a lot of
their content and I thought that was
really obvious with the Nicole Kidman
AMC thing so I didn't see that one
so Nicole Kidman you know when you go to
the movies and before they play um AMC
has this like new one with Nicole Kidman
we come here for magic and it's like it
blew up on Tick Tock people were like
recreating it in the theaters it was so
funny because it's like it's so random
and she's like taking it so seriously
like we come here to live
and people on Tick Tock blew it up and
they basically just made like a high
budget high production value Tick Tock
and it was almost like literally
stealing the idea from Tick Tock so I'm
like you're gonna lean in so heavy to
tick tock and not address the Jake no
back of it all like bring Jake Novak out
right give him a shot also he auditioned
for your show and it ruined his [ __ ]
life the Charmin Bears sketch when they
danced to about damn time is that
Tick-Tock dance
yes and they use the choreography I
wonder if they paid the the girls who
made it up probably not but that's
another tick tock
oh man yeah and I'm glad that they're
like at least moving into the 21st
century
um but like
I don't know it felt like the greatest
you know
what is supposed to be like the peak of
entertainment and comedy on television
is like taking notes from teenagers on
and also I didn't watch the whole
episode but from what I saw like there
are so many things that are just like
happening everything is like such a joke
and there's so much spotter out there
right now to like actually make fun of
and instead like I'm seeing Two Bros who
don't know how to flirt at the bar being
stupid like also the opening sketch like
was Trump and they really like they've
beat the horse dead like it's enough
it's not even funny anymore like I feel
like you know Trump like definitely
exists but like he's not on social media
like I feel like I never hear about him
except
they're obsessed and one I think they
like and it's not funny no it's not
funny I think that was kind of like the
point of the sketch let's see what they
do next week but like for every like for
the last few years every opening sketch
is like a Mitch McConnell Nancy Pelosi
Trump and it's like I get it like
there's political things happening and
like it's a show that's supposed to make
fun of what's going on in the world but
like they've gotta switch it up oh
there's other players that are right for
making fun of and 100 like it's time
no I'm like girly it's been three years
since the man has been president like we
haven't even heard from him in three
years like he's not on social media like
I'm like it doesn't feel relevant
anymore because it's just like it's like
oh they're obsessed
yeah like
I I feel like it's a it's like time's up
on that joke yeah
so it was good I'd love to see miles
he's so handsome and so he's handsome
really extra handsome especially in
those pictures that they like run yes
one of them was like a slow video and
he's like turning and smiling and I was
like yeah I also think um he brought his
acting chops like he wasn't reading from
cue cards he memorized the lines he was
being like a real actor so I was like
believing what he was selling he was
amazing yeah no he's a perfect host
because he's so beloved and he's out so
an actor and he's funny and he obviously
is an SNL file from that home video that
we saw yes oh that was so cute really
cute
and he's really like America's
sweetheart current yes so what better
place for America's sweetheart than in
all of our televisions in all of our
homes on Saturday I can't believe that
was his first time hosting I would have
thought he would have done it
um I also loved the call out that like
they couldn't get Jon Hammer Tom Cruise
so they went with Miles and Miles as
Peyton was like well I also heard that
uh the host never makes an appearance
and they'll get a sketch so it was very
funny very meta I liked that a lot yeah
me too
and the new castmates I didn't really
see a lot of them but they did good uh I
only saw four sketches I'll try much
more
so that is our show and that is the
toast the toast
thank you so much for listening to the
Millennium no wait what do I say thank
you so much for listening Millennial
podcast Morning Show the millennial oh
right thank you so much for listening to
the toast the millennial podcast where
we deliver the past five stories you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found on Spotify iTunes theater
public radio iHeartRadio castbox all the
places where we listen to podcasts find
us more details leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
and we'll see you tomorrow for Tuesday's
show and I'll see you guys tonight at
the Westbury Plaza Total Wine for the
Spritz Society meet and greet I can't
wait to see you guys there bye